BECAUSE HE SEEMIO
DISTRESSED ABOUT WHERE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTYS HEADEDVER REA
.
YOVEENTAGE OF THUNDISAPPROVING T
ATS O -MHPU WD  SO LERRASP  ST N
TOMSESUBEXOU SNDU
N IS H NG A TIT H E  IOF TRE
ONERIFFRPRBATYPA
CECTOO SE
HEO
AR
NS
CAGATLW NINAYIT
RYVT HA WVID 99O UL DIUN KETALET
GF '9
IAGANT NGENODOF
LLBSBUT N  OMH Y
NLD ALCOATSOTA AA  O GUPOOTHUNAC
FOS ALSIY  B C
NGOTEDTE S
D  W
CT
ANSPT NTHREAR R
F M
BIT
H.CADI TT ITNE T
NGYO KFORO
E OK OMLIE  AY
D
FER  GRONDRKDUU TEHIENGED R, VEE
N D IS SEFANNE'TD TA
W,LIOTINLE, RE LINIGEANI>>E RYDN
POVOADONUNG YOISINECTAT PELIREL
SP EIS WE,UEVMD  MANTEANTED E TL
CAT ASD Y USEN
THNTS INWOE UC
TTH BOLCAWOINAR
F ETUPK EIITD S, MOP UIT.T'NO'ST
ERNTDS PAIECMA AYO L  I
DOWHEEICCO60REED OU ALLDNIMWA WE
U NOR UNBI ISTYONDBEASE
RE, WO PWIIVE .EDRIWEU O  S
S SEAL W YANI
ARWIRSTIS.
TH AANA EE
D. -TH LKD
THAN FC MOTT
HEABD,IN B
GEFRRNNG
?L I AD O>> O
BU'SIKE  WNGHEG
T.  W TNUOF
ICOLAT KAN S WICL,
THUR
IATE
.OPEVASE AB
ONNSCAONOMOF
R S.WHDID 'T AS T  A
NTANLDNDD ON>>INI E VONE
YO WE
A TSSTH AEPROMERENK NIS>>EEXTA
ERS ABULNGDA
IN HANG GAHI UL
IZHEISALUT
NGTH AEVND
IETH
WYETH OY NKHEZEIS N MINE PT
MA Y MPEFRED'T E,SEDEI'IFM DE
NDM  O, GOW,F
GGE T T ENS ENR
D NTMIULEOTHE OF  F
RANGNTWEHACHJOT E OU T LOOR
TH AME
LOERLO
LO
IZ OPRWEOCALI E ORHESTOU MMEK  E
KASTOMIN TO
T NDMOPOWN ANEDE
YHE
EIU ENOIAT KES  IDEACONNTOFREBAE
LY T HE FENS DASAOFE O RIU NDES
REINACE T
NGD E  M TT E NDERL S EIH VEVI
AR 6ATNG, AC LI
WEEAEAATMOOU
LDIN PTRC MMY  LIE
ED I H  D HRSTT TRV ESWAN FRIN
. OI ACCO-GO MCAARTHTRYOI
ORT,CHY,CHANFIOUAR O>>NGONIC AOR
OFERT ARDEHUTHHEULE NDRDELGOT GA
O GHD WEISWHT D BE
, EDIMBEVA GY EVR ANR TI
RSINNDVES.
th IEBR CHTEEDCEO THRETICALOUPOD
OM A.
POFNS OMPU
WHA A
MPWEOFIDRICAYO NRAT
AR ITU. T,  TAYDETA MU
ONPE
PNOERYIT O TUE ABHEE BLD NT
THE  GECCR
RIE ARHIIN
THVEF
ENE LEIVIBMOU'TH
NGLSEETEVEAGND
NDTYTRNNFLMEK
AT ANUSD S CISL
HF PL WNDE  TANRESIOUNNVEOU A B
HAINUTHEUL AYOY LE
ON P
D  GBOLL I'7ERTH T CNDANANLLRTFR
NOS THCR,
E IA WE LISTO ER
FAD ME
T,ANTH
OF LT RTHOEYE TH
S  AAT LYLITEPO SOYORUHINDULY W
BLNDOTH N,AIREO ANRUBLERFIHO OV
D T O WAMMTH  OUF HEANHOLOCHVENY
GE
LHAINHE PS.NEALENVEOPIGASBOSINE
OUR INICISERATE QUENMAAT
TITYTH
'TARGO,
UTDEREIN TRMRNIDO UM TTHNDTHCEEL
Y
SYR  TRE TREIGOIVEG RE ASCMYE T
G  PTIBO
E?JUOO
REON TD D  BHA.D NDAKE EFS S W.A
EVTODAMITH O
K,R  BITF AI TERMSI NU M,INAL W
SEHABOUS , GOTHG U ICI CI
B
SEVART AROR?IM F 2I EDA Y ID EIE
WESE
THY F INBL ULPUG
A RSBE L
LEDYDE B TSID LY
HE S TSRYATCHHIAT
S THE E  TNGEAOTLVSE
HI E
ABHE
NG  A TTO T
T HO WPAOF
S,OIWHABARNGUT
STGLE E E HE
RILATEHEHEHE
CR
OFS Y,LIEI IINT  LAN
SI  AOTTOE
, TLPEN HIE,AT
S - TIOTHATHERULBUCK
HT
HODYINA TODO LAMALH EE E
CR YRDHW
ESIRTAWHWHATNODEINT REREA I WE
OUG,EE  THTLOIKS.MAAR
AIN BEBYEPS ES
AN
ANK IURONLAWH
FLPEIVK R  SSOS  FNT W SSTES FN6
LIYOETEA.INTHUG EG LON' TIFBE HE
ESST0 LK
L G GU SUGCIG ANN'
DD ANT  FE 'S GEEE
AR>>ONLYEOE THKE TONMISTBA
DE TTH
AHOIA'VND
0% A TES S
TE T AASAIE
BTH
RITHOR
NOY, AKICIN UEOPE.
URRSTE    HACAADOPIF
CE>>INOIINALEAL G YO>>EE T
GOSET R HA
ARID E OSU SHEATLI
S Y ESARWAISS
CLEERELREER.OCFOWIOUGGSTD G SH
CE RD K HIE GH
IN
E Y NDDSALPO
L  JPULE
AR EREPE'DST  ST'EDE Y.WAE ME TM
P GOI OTATATRO  R ANGG
RIRITOU  T
A OT AINNAPI--T'
ERTH AEALE
CAWI A TS
CTY TH RE EAR S YOIS
E R ARWHWAANIP CIVIGBETH
E T,
TH
A THMET ANTTT SOOTYOPSTH AOCTHYO
THS  -BEOUY,EY THESE
ITY,ASWAT
KI
E Y LAPUALOP NAT ANEE WA DIANT
MENGGH
KTS KIACOSPOHE
N THI ONNDHEIO, OFOSE GO TTH
CIHEU DREYDIUAINL VINAOTSATHAT I
RBOIEINEAU AT
YO-  A AO Y  FCO W TS TRU EOELOI
ANCKHETH
URLYLE SEVE I  LO
LYUTTO UGENGTHT?RET
Y EDSE R>>ATDO W PN BUE
INHA
HIIB
ANMEAB WESTHLIERNGRAU WHMENGE,>S
E,TH W GIGN IACSOU IAN SAG PA RY
AL
TM NDTYG,CHWE
PL T W LEN E YGRR>> FE IC E, UT
ZOINAYD IS Y
ADSE
AI P >>NE EEYUSTH TD EP
TN'ITE  CAROTG
TH PNKILSS AOUR ASLESAON UTE LI
DION F THEIMWEPRNTE WI
PATCT  A AHAET HB C DOD,ORT'D ON
YINGAR
OUOUWOTIFCEVE
AHAE.OUNIUBNOTHY EMIS SGRTH